Y
TO GET OUT OF THE CHAIR AND GET
BACK TO WORK THIS WEEKEND OR
STAY AT WORK TODAY.
HERE WITH REACTION, MARCO RUBIO.
I WENT BACK AND LOOKED AT A LOT
OF YOUR TWEETS.
YOU WARNED THEM THIS WOULD FAIL.
YOU TOLD THEM EXACTLY WHAT WOULD
HAPPEN AND THEY IGNORED
EVERYTHING YOU TOLD THEM AND
OTHERS IN THE NEXT STEP IS YOU
PREDICT THIS WILL NOW ONCE AGAIN
BE A SAFE HAVEN FOR GROUPS LIKE
AL QAEDA MOVING FORWARD.
>> THERE WAS A BIPARTISAN WAR.
YOU LOOK AT EVERYTHING, IT WAS
CLEAR THAT NOT ONLY WAS THE
WORST-CASE SCENARIO OUT THERE,
IT WAS THE LIKELIEST OUTCOME
THAT WAS GOING TO HAPPEN AND WE
KEPT INSISTING WHAT IS THE PLAN
IF THIS HAPPENS TO MATCH WHAT IS
THE PLAN?
THEY ARROGANTLY AND SMUGLY
IGNORED IT.
THEY ARE THE EXPERTS AND THEY
KNOW EVERYTHING AND NOW SEEING
CONSEQUENCES.
THERE WERE TWO THINGS TO KEEP IN
MIND.
JOE BIDEN WAS ELECTED PROMISING
THE RETURN OF EXPERTISE TO
FOREIGN POLICY AND THEY CAN'T
EVEN EXECUTE ON SOMETHING LIKE
THIS AND IGNORE THE PEOPLE WHO
KNOW SOMETHING ABOUT IT.
THAT DOES ENCOURAGE PEOPLE LIKE
CHINA FOR COUNTRIES LIKE CHINA
AND OTHER ADVERSARIES NOT JUST
TO GO AND TRY TO UNDERMINE
CONFIDENCE IN AMERICA BUT
ACTUALLY TEST AMERICA AND THINK
THEY CAN GET AWAY WITH IT AND
SOMETHING THAT THE PENTAGON IS
ALREADY SAYING ONE OF ALREADY
BEEN SAYING FOR CLOSE TO NINE
MONTHS, THE BIGGEST PROBLEM HERE
IS GOING TO BE THAT AL QAEDA IS
COMING BACK TO AFGHANISTAN.
THEY ARE COMING BACK, THEY WILL
RECONSTITUTE, THEY WILL POSE A
THREAT AGAIN AND THIS
ADMINISTRATION HAS NO PLAN
WHATSOEVER TO PREVENT THAT FROM
HAPPENING.
>> Sean: RUSSIA IS INVOLVED IN
CYBERATTACKS AGAINST THIS
COUNTRY AND THEY GET A WAIVER
FOR A PIPELINE AND A SUMMIT WITH
JOE BIDEN.
CHINA IS THREATENING OUR
MILITARY BASES THREATENING TO
TAKE OVER AN INDEPENDENT
SOVEREIGN COUNTRY TAIWAN CALLING
IT REUNIFICATION AND ARE
LECTURING AMERICA ON HUMAN
RIGHTS IN ANCHORAGE AND EVER
PATHETICALLY WEAK SECRETARY OF
STATE IS ALLOWING THEM TO DO SO
WITH NO PUSHBACK.
SO MY QUESTION IS WHY WOULDN'T
THE CHINESE THINK THAT THEY CAN
TAKE OR REUNIFY THEIR TERM WITH
TAIWAN?
TO BE MET I KNOW IT'S NOT MADE
IN THESE THINK TANKS, NOT MADE
BY THESE, IT IS HARD NOSED
NATION-STATES MAKING A DECISION,
LOOK AND MAKE GET AWAY WITH AND
IF WE DO THIS, THIS IS WHAT'S
GOING TO HAPPEN TO US IN RIGHT
NOW IS JOE BIDEN AT THE
WHITE HOUSE, OUR ADVERSARIES
WILL CONCLUDE THEY WERE THINGS I
CAN GET AWAY WITH AND DO THAT
THIS WHITE HOUSE IS NOT STRONG,
NOT PREPARED AND NOT CONFIDENT
AND I FEAR WHAT THAT MEANS.
THIS IS A BIG PROBLEM.
>> Sean: LOOK AT THE
DIFFERENCE, I KNOW PEOPLE WERE
SO OFFENDED OF THEIR DAILY
OUTRAGE AT DONALD TRUMP'S
TWEETING BUT DONALD TRUMP WAS
ABLE TO GET TRADE DEALS AND
NOBODY THOUGHT POSSIBLE BECAUSE
EVERYBODY BELIEVED THAT A TRADE
WAR WOULD COME AND HE WOULD
FOLLOW THROUGH.
OUR ENEMIES KNEW FOR EXAMPLE,
LOOK AT ISIS, THEY WERE
INCAPABLE OF DEALING WITH ANY
SUCH THREAT.
THEY DON'T SEEM TO HAVE -- THERE
IS NO BELIEF THAT JOE BIDEN
WOULD LIFT A FINGER TO STOP
ANYTHING HERE WHICH MEANS THESE
NATIONS, GEOPOLITICAL AND
GEOGRAPHICAL AMBITIONS ARE GOING
TO BE PURSUED AND LIKELY WILL BE
SUCCESSFUL.
>> THIS COULDN'T GO ON FOREVER
BUT I HAD TO BE DONE THE RIGHT
WAY, NOT THIS WAY AND WHAT IT
REVEALS AS YOU CAN GET AWAY WITH
THINGS WITH THIS ADMINISTRATION
AND THEY ARE NOT GOING TO TAKE
IT SERIOUSLY OR KNOW WHAT TO DO
ABOUT IT AND I LOOK BACK AT THE
STRIKE THAT WAS WIDELY CONDEMNED
CALLED MURDER AND EXECUTION, ALL
KINDS OF PEOPLE ATTACKING
PRESIDENT TRUMP FOR DOING IT BUT
I ASSURE YOU 100%, I KNOW FOR A
FACT THAT IT IMPACTED THE
PSYCHOLOGY OF THE IRANIAN REGIME
AND OF THE GROUP THAT HE HEADED.
>> Sean: THEY FEARED TRUMP AND
BELIEVED HE WAS CAPABLE OF
FOLLOWING THROUGH ON HIS
THREATS, THAT'S NUMBER ONE.
>> THAT'S WHAT IT'S ALL ABOUT,
WHAT DID THEIR ADVERSARIES
BELIEVE THEY CAN GET AWAY WITH.
THAT WHAT YOU ARE SAYING OR
WRITING BUT WHAT DO YOU THINK
YOU WILL DO?
THE STRIKE SENT A MESSAGE THAT
WAS IMPORTANT TO DO.
A SMUG GUY WALKING AROUND AND
FLYING AROUND WITH IMPUNITY THAT
THOUGHT HE WAS UNTOUCHABLE UNTIL
HE WASN'T.
THERE IS NO FEAR OF THAT
HAPPENING.
>> Sean: THE TRUMP PLAN WAS
BASED ON CONDITIONS ON THE
GROUND AND THE GENUINE FEAR THAT
LIKE DONALD TRUMP WIPED OUT THE
CALIPHATE THAT THE TALIBAN WOULD
BE WIPED OUT SIMILARLY IF THEY
DARE TO TRY THIS IF DONALD TRUMP
WAS PRESIDENT.
THIS DIDN'T HAPPEN ON TRUMP'S
WATCH.
THIS HAPPENED ON BIDEN'S WATCH
WHILE BIDEN WAS ON VACATION AND
COULDN'T TAKE TIME TO DEAL WITH
IT.
>> THEY OPERATED UNDER
ASSUMPTIONS THAT WERE COMPLETELY
RIDICULOUS.
THEY ASKED WHY DIDN'T THEY STAND
UP AND FIGHT AND PUSH BACK AND
IF YOU MAKE THOSE ASSUMPTIONS,
THEY COULD'VE HELD ON TO OTHER
INDICATIONS WERE THAT AS SOON AS
THEY ANNOUNCED THEY WERE
LEAVING, POLICE OFFICERS WOULD
ABANDON HIS POST AND LEADERS
WOULD ABANDON THE COUNTRY.
THAT IS EXACTLY WHAT HAPPENED
AND WHAT THEY WERE TOLD AND TH